pour beaucoup d'émotion parce qu'on
retrouve toute l'équipe
tous ceux avec qui j'ai passé sept ans
quand même tous les jours par des bustes
et bavures et donc un tour beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion et de nostalgie ou
incomplètement bien sûr on va visiter
ces les sept plus bas les avez allaité
laisser passer donc évidemment il a le
statut même si aujourd'hui je suis passé
à autre chose
la matinale c'est un autre boulot c'est
vraiment quelque chose j'ai beaucoup de
temps mais je regarde régulièrement les
questions et je retrouve les mêmes
colonnes les mêmes elles mêmes inimitiés
les mêmes coups de gueule et même cyril
cas pas changé la prod cas pas changer
le passé c'est super là en l'occurrence
ils m'ont demandé si je vais jamais une
question à poser à jean michel qui après
du coup nous aussi ça nous embête être
passé pour faire une petite séquence
donc voici 3 a pris beaucoup de plaisir
je peux rien fidèles c'est lui qui m'a
donné ma chance au coeur je peux pas
dire refuser ça et l'idée du déguisement
ah ça c'est ça c'est ça qui est
formidable
deux heures bon ça n'a pas marché qui
sont aussi moche mais c'est pas classe
intégrer ces quelques belles tel fou
rire que c'était drôle
alors ce qui est drôle c'est que tout le
monde a reconnu sur taksim
alors qu'en fait c'était pour maxime
auxi maxime et si personne n'avait rien
dit je pense que maxime serait rentré
dans le jeu et ça c'est le rose et je me
compte maximisée
quelques mois